vince
i uh i have that quarterly analysis that
you asked for
i had a quarter of these nuts on your
chin
seriously
[Music]
all right where you headed youngster
yeah i'm uh headed to the cobol building
on jefferson all right yeah cobo hall
jefferson avenue
so uh what what you in detroit for i
gotta do a presentation all right okay
yeah presentation okay you know
where you present
uh
actually it's about how market research
can be interpreted with out-of-the-box
solutions oh all right so you won't get
this all outside the box all right
most people think that uh all customers
are a single demographic oh okay you try
to get all them demographics up in here
all right all right yeah
online trends are less linear oh okay
online trans
linea
also thinking about doing the
presentation naked
no clothes on oh yeah yeah naked
presentation no clothes on that's good
afterward i might just piss on the floor
in front of everyone oh yeah okay all
right piss him right there up in front
of everybody
all right so good then i might just
shoot everybody in the place you know
with the gun i'm hiding in my ass yeah
your gun way up in that ass that's the
way to do it cut my victims faces off
wear them as masks yeah masks go on the
face ah yeah okay
ickben9 shine
hitler yep okay hi hello
all right here we are
oh by the way
when you kill those people with your ass
gun make sure to use a serrated blade to
cut the faces off
i'll feed his name
[Music]
vince
i uh i have that quarterly analysis that
you asked for
i had a quarter of these nuts on your
chin
right
it's just that i wanted to review some
of these numbers with you it seems like
our earnings are low against our
original projections
these nuts were low against your chin
[Music]
you know vince
if you ever need to talk to me about
something i'm more than happy to listen
these nuts will be more than happy to
rest against your chin
[Music]
hey look you've been doing this for
about a week now and it was kind of
funny at first these nuts were kind of
funny against your chin
i've been so worried about you
[Music]
i was worried about these nuts on your
chin
stand seriously
these nuts were seriously on your chin
mr graham i just got a call from st
mary's hospital and your parents were in
a serious car accident
i'm so sorry
but your mother is dead
and your father is on life support
[Music]
these nuts are supporting life on your
chin
sorry amber
vince you gotta stop it
your mother just passed away these nuts
passed away on your [ __ ] no they didn't
they didn't vince
listen you gotta leave here right now
and go be with your dad this could be
the last time that you get to see him
it's gonna be the last time i get to see
my knots on your goddamn it vincent
your father might be dying
these nuts might be dying on your chin
[Music]
god damn it fans snap the [ __ ] out of it
your mother is dead
all right
you're right
you okay okay you're all right you're
back
i don't know what came over me that's
all right it was so good
it was just
it worked in every situation
i know i know and it's always it's just
so funny well it wasn't it wasn't that
it was funny
it really wasn't that funny vince
really funny
i would not go so far as to say it was
really funny vince is funny
but it wasn't though
it was
it wasn't
i created disagree it's funny okay
that's fine
one more time i just got to go on record
to sing it wasn't really that funny
i go see my dad okay
that was funny
wasn't that funny
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dad
stay with me
dad
i love you
and i love
these nuts on your chin
these nuts from your chin
[Music]
morning
ron good morning
how's the fam
oh i don't have one i'm single sir i'm
not married i do have a girlfriend
that's great she's not oh god
[Music]
hey i need you to do me a favor
make sure everybody knows that the
bagels are for sales associates only
no problem sir
[Music]
all right let's get this sales
presentation started
all right who's hungover
i know ron is
that's not true you're an alcoholic
i'm not sir i'm not
hey guys
sales associates
friends
today i want to talk about
the world's oldest profession
hold on hold on i know i know what
you're thinking right sex and
prostitutes that's not what i'm talking
about
okay
talking about sales
if you look at our ancient history as
human beings the first caveman out there
sold a rock to the second caveman out
there
the bagels are just for sales associates
plus hail no it's it's free
all for free
not not for you though it's just for me
no
to define ourselves
the bagels are only for sales associate
ron
love the enthusiasm but it's a little
distracting
i'm sorry i'm sorry sir uh don't do it
again please sorry
moving on for me maybe no not not maybe
i'm i'm sorry i'm so sorry
what for us for us no no not for us one
there's one it's just that they're for
sales associates only for me maybe
and then it's
helpful
okay
yep
just shut up all right
what was the first tongue twister you
remember hearing
was it she sells
sir what else sir
cream cheese is also only for sales
associates outcome is not for me why
because the bagels are for sale
yes time and place man i'm sorry this
guy just keeps trying to grab a baby
do you want to come up here and do the
presentation i'll go back there and be a
jackass you just asked me to make sure
that nobody would oh the science says my
name's ron i like to drink alcohol and
listen to science all day
he's really relentless about having a
man
and hate all your bagels i'm trying
unbelievable everybody
all right i'll just i'll start cold
cells make up our bodies but selling
makes our bodies come alive
thanks rob seriously
no no no you can't have any bagels you
can't have any cream cheese and you
can't have smells that's what the
all right you know what
just give me a minute i'm gonna try to
forget ron ruined my day
because this presentation is great and
it's going great
i think you guys can bagel too he's big
hey this is
he's right mom
mr cook you're almost up are you ready
good i'm good
okay really gonna need you to stick to
the script on this one i'm the ceo of
apple willis i'm not gonna do anything
stupid please stop comparing me to steve
jobs no but nobody's comparing you to
steve jobs okay we just want you to
focus on the products and
please stick to the script okay uh
you're on in three they're gonna forget
they ever heard the name steve jobs
[Applause]
well now the first thing that i'm gonna
do
is t o
throw
out
the
scripts
now
i'm supposed to come out here and tell
you about some bull
that's exactly it
now let's see this table right here
let's say it's bill gates huh
[Applause]
that's what i'm talking about and let's
say
that this
is our competitor's
new smartphone
how about that now what
i am
right and let's say that this right here
this
is one of our competitors new ebook
reader huh what about that what oh
looks like wayne
[Music]
[Applause]
who wants to see some of that classified
next level huh
did steve ever show you that classified
no we did you can't do that they haven't
been tested yet this device will allow
you to teleport anywhere on the planet
check this out
i
am the future
let's see steve jobs do that
marjorie i'd love a cupcake
thank you so much for coming today uh as
you know every year the vice president
hosts the annual company luncheon uh so
i brought you here to make sure that
none of my material could be in any way
misconstrued as sexist or racist or
homophobic so if you hear anything that
could be in any way offensive to anyone
just raise your hand and
oh i haven't really started yet uh did
you find something offensive the fact
that you think i need a man's permission
to raise my hand is insane i can raise
my hand whenever i want to raise my hand
because i'm a free woman so i should
just raise my hand like this like a big
old black power fist yeah huh boss man
is that what you want from me is this
what you wanted a floppy gay hand just
floating around in the air well here you
go here's my floppy gay hand at the end
of my limp gay wrist happy no jesus no
wow what why not mary no or rachel no or
bathsheba no why does it have to be
jesus a man and are we talking about the
jesus that accepts everyone or the jesus
who doesn't believe that people should
be able to love who they love oh maybe i
should just break out in some gospel
song screaming and hollering hooting oh
lordy lordy no this isn't the speech yet
can i just do the speech oh you want
this [ __ ] to shut up is that it what's
the matter the black guys making way too
much noise in your movie theater messer
forgive me for lisping and lilting
through your speech no i just meant
with the hands man i ain't gonna shoot
you or are you gonna grab my breasts now
protect yourself from the gay invasion
guys oh guys should i leave sorry men
and women let's exclude everybody who
identifies themselves as something else
because they're not people i meant
people who's people my people do i speak
for my people all right more like all
white more like no rights more like
women are second-class citizens
right okay stop
men women people of all ethnicities
genders
sexual orientation religion can i please
just get to my speech
fine yeah
okay here goes
a [ __ ] a pole lock and an arab walk
into a bar i love arab jokes
bring it on you had me at pollock
noah sanders here for the uh job
interview please take a seat mr
weinstein we'll see you next
[Music]
[Applause]
job interviews huh
never fun
okay
i get it stay focused
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's a big laugh
oh no
[Laughter]
this is a job interviewer the carol
burnett show you know what i mean
oh my god that is too rich thanks so
much for coming in adam of course and
you better stay away from that chinese
oh my god you got that right that's
doing that number on my stomach
oh
here's your fortune you're gonna be sick
oh my gosh what an absolute delight it's
been great and can i tell you something
i don't even care if i get this job
because i know i've made a friend for
life
what a terrific attitude
what a great goddamn attitude yeah you
son of a gun
you know what
[Music]
right quick before you leave i want to
give you something no sir i can't take
any more gifts this whole thing has been
a gift
my brother passed away
[Music]
21 years ago
we were estranged
and he became ill
and he gave this to me as a peace
offering
and then one day when we were on the
ocean he fell overboard on a boat very
much like this one and died
i saw him struggling all the way as a
riptide just pulled him down [ __ ] ocean
would you please accept this as a as a
token of my gratitude for you bringing
joy back into my life
under any other circumstance i would
refuse
but i will accept this gift today
because i know how much it means to you
so i will
thank you
oh i made it
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
this guy how do you keep a straight face
all day
and she's sweet sweeter than five oh my
god god damn it i love your
energy well all right what can i say sir
i am solar powered
really you like you like that one huh
oh thanks so much adam terrific
best interview i've ever been a part of
in my entire life
okay who's next
you ready let's go chop chop here we go
come on let's go
okay
requesting permission to come on board
sir hi noah sanders name uh sorry to
hear about your brother maybe we can get
some chinese food after this all right
all right okay take it easy
jeez settle down turbo
[Music]